hello my name is amit paz
this is going to work with pierre frenio
franz faragal and
hawa mishi mishimova and i will tell you
today about distributed quantum proofs
for replicated data
so in the replicated data problem we
have a system a network
represented by its communication graph
as seen here
and there is some there are some pieces
of data replicated among
some of the terminals more some of the
units of the network
so we have a data center we have data
centers
uh connected by network and some of the
data centers contain network that should
be identical
in all of them and we want to verify
that all these copies of that are indeed
the same
of course a classical and very useful
problem
and today we'll talk about one mechanism
of how to verify this
how to verify that the replicas of that
are indeed the same
so we want that if older because that's
okay is in the left
everything is okay we can continue
computing as usual in the network
and if it's not okay as in the right one
of the
reference of data goes corrupted then
some unit resonance says something is
wrong and we have to recompute or
re-replicate the data
so this question is the type of question
studied under title of distributed
certification or distributed
verification
and was studied a lot before under names
like proof leveling schemes
locally checkout proofs and recently
industrial interactive proofs
and this work we'll talk about how to
extend these mechanisms to use quantum
bits
so we think of a mechanism that have two
ingredients one is the prover above that
c is all the network and wants to help
the units
to verified state and the other is the
units themselves
the verifiers that have to verify the
state of the system in our case that the
replicated data
is consistent so and we have also two
phases in the first phase
the prover on top assigns certificates
the units these certificates will help
them to verify
and in the second phase the units
exchange certificates or send messages
between them
each unit will talk only to its
immediate neighbors in the network
and then they have to decide if they
think their state of the system is okay
or not
so our goal is to assign certificates to
the units or to have
uh to allow the approver to assign
certificates
such that if all the replicas are
identical the stellar system is okay
then all nodes accept we think of the
nodes as just turing machines
or find automatons and just have to
accept all of them
and later they may reuse these
certificates
to verify the state again and again so
we think of a long-lived
network that may be used a lot with for
a lot of things
and more other things the network does
is to verify the state of the replicated
data
in the background and periodically and
reuse these certificates to verify it
again and again
if something goes wrong say one of the
replicas of the data goes corrupted then
at least one of the units have to
identify we say it rejected
and it rejects the state of the system
and then
the unit will have to recompute
re-replicate the data and also get
or compute new certificates
and maybe one of the questions that you
may ask yourself now is how do you get
these certificates it's kind of weird
mechanism
and we actually have two answers for
that one is
let's say you build a network so you
have one-time
initialization of the network or you
assign
the data replicate the data then the
units of network will also
create certificates that will help them
to check later that the data is
still okay so this is one time
initialization
another way is to just think of an
external entity say cloud that sees all
the network and all the replicated data
and tries to help us to verify the state
lb units to verify the state of the
system and the
replicated data and our goal in this
mechanism is to use small certificates
and also small messages
because you keep the certificates in
memory maybe you will keep
replicating replicas of them in the
local member of each unit
and you also send them so you would want
to send small matches
because these are sent in the background
and you don't want it to interfere
with the regular uh work of the system
and these kind of mechanisms were
studied a lot both in practice
because they're useful for four terms
network this is a way to detect
failures or changes that are the change
the state of the system
but also in theory because actually
another way to think of these
certificates is as weaknesses in non
uh computation like in the np class
so while most research in distributable
building is
more like p is about computing or
deciding state of the system without
certificates
these mechanisms have to do with
non-deterministic computation
where you think of the certificates as
witnesses for non-deterministic
computation
okay so now let's see a simple example
how you can use certificates
to verify the state of the system or of
the replicated data in this case
and this will be a trivial one where the
certificate just contain
all the data again so the proverb will
assign to each of the nodes
the full data full replica the data as a
certificate
and now in the verification phase the
unit will check two things
if a unit has it as data it will check
that the certificate it got
is the same as the data and in addition
they all exchange certificates with
their neighbors
and each unit will check that its
certificate is the same as the
certificate of its neighbors
we assume the network is connected so if
every two neighbors have the same
certificates then
all the units has the same certificates
if everything is okay
in this example all you need to accept
and say everything is okay
if something is wrong say one of the
replicas of the data
is not as it should be it's not the same
as the other replicas
then one option is to get the same
certificate as before
most of units are still happy i think
everything is okay but the unit that has
the wrong
data sees that there is a problem and
raise alarm and then they can be
replicated another option is that the
certificates also go wrong
as in this example still many
universities would think everything is
okay and specifically all the units with
the replicated data in them
we think everything is okay but other
units
will see something is wrong because a
unit and its neighbor don't have the
same certificate
so among all the edges that separate the
wrong certificates and the correct
certificates
we will have units that translate and
say
something is not okay we have to
replicate data and create new
certificates
this is a very nice simple example and
for this mechanism
but the certificates are huge and
they're
as big as the replicated when we think
of rare packets
data in this example when this question
has been very large maybe much larger
than the network itself
so this is the first parameter we care
about and the size of data know that
here
n is like in communication complexity
itself that i note
the size of the network which is usually
used in distributed computing
we also see the number of terminals
storing data and hour the radius of the
terminals that is the large distance
between warfare terminals and all the
others
and our goal as i mentioned before is to
minimize both the certificate size and
the message sizes
so using quantum bits or distributed
quantum computation was studied
a lot before but not for verification
and the main idea of this work is to use
quantum bits as certificates and as
messages and let's see how we do it
so the first thing we do in this work is
to define this mechanism of distributed
quantum alien article proofs
or there are disabled quantum
certification
the first result shows that there is a
distributed quantum metal in the auto
protocol for the radical replicated data
problem
uh with some parameters the most
important one
uh most interesting one for this target
list
is the dependence on n the size of the
data
which is only logarithmic the number of
qubits in the certificates and in the
messages
is only logarithmic in the size of the
data
and we also show that a classical
protocol without using quantum bits
requires linear size certificates or
messages you cannot get
get as low as log and certificate and
messages
if you don't use quantum bits and this
is true even if randomization is allowed
so these problems really have
exponential separation between the
certificated message size within the
quantum regime and the classical regime
and i should say that all the uh
scale of these certificates is usually
up to linear or quadratic
we don't think of exponentials as
certificates we can
celebrate much less and our goal is to
get constant or logarithmic sides
so linear size here is a very bad answer
this is why we wanted to use quantum
bits to get much better answers
so the main idea the main result as i
mentioned
is to get logarithmic size certificates
logarithmic in the side of the
replicated data and i will show you this
today on a line
where the graph is only a line and i
will only only has two terminals
a and b that have the data on them
and so
we start from asking what happened if a
and b
alice and bob are neighbors they are
immediate neighbors
they can talk to one another directly
not with a line
not with a line between them graph of a
path
but their immediate neighbors and this
question was actually
studied and answered in the regime of
communication complexity
where you don't have a whole network but
just two players alice in both that want
to check something in this
for in this case they want to check
equality of their inputs
and this is input x bob is input y don't
check that x equals y
and one way to do this using
randomization is use a random hash
function
so alice will choose a random hash
function
h from the family of hash functions send
to bob
h the function itself and h of x
the hash of the input of alice and bob
can verify that the hash on its input y
equals to the hash
on else's input hx that he got as a
message
and the probability that this happens if
the inputs x and y are not the same
can be made arbitrarily small by
choosing large enough
family hash functions so we can actually
solve the problem very
easily with small messages using
randomization
if l's and bob are neighbors but in our
case we have a path that
may be much longer than one h so can we
do the same
uh so the trivial thing will say okay
let's have the approver
give the hash of the input x
to all the units in the network to all
the units on the path
but this can actually this actually does
not work
because the hash functions function must
be chosen at
random otherwise the prover may try to
fool us
and give us hash function of
x the input values and even if bob has
input y that is different to the hash
functions that
such that hx and hy are equal
and of course this hash function exists
just the probation to choose it at
random is very small
so we cannot trust the proverb to choose
the function
because he may fool us another thing we
can do
is to choose a random function but then
we have to interact with the approver to
send a question to the approver
send the prover the hash function of
course there are also mechanisms that
allow this but this is not what we
discussed today
when you want to get one-time hashes
one-time certificates and use them again
and again and not
interact with approver or do some
complicated things like that
so you cannot just have the hash
function as the certificate
in our setting what can we do instead
well using quantum bits as expected
maybe
the idea will be the following the
certificate will be a quantum
fingerprint
of x the replicated data
so what is this quantum fingerprint it's
a
superposition of quantum states
representing the all the different hash
functions
and for each other's functions function
also the hash of x
the input first we have these pairs
h h x as we had had before in the
communication complexity setting and we
still we have a superposition of
all these for all the possible hash
functions from our family
functions and this takes logarithm
quantum beads
and what is the verification procedure
here
well the units will check that all the
certificates are identical by just
checking that the certificate of every
two neighbor is the same
and each node that also has an input x
will check that
the quantum fingerprint of x
equals to the certificate it got
okay so they all take equality
and terminals know that have input also
takes at the input
the hash of the input is the same as the
certificate
so this looks very simple but actually
there are many details to consider
here i'll mention uh the challenges we
have
to meet or the problems we had to freeze
the first is how do we even check
equality of quantum stats
there are answers for this but we had to
pick one this is good
and more interesting maybe
question is the no cloning property of
quantum states
so actually what we think of is look
we have this node v in the network we
will send it certificate to b
to the right and receive certificates
from you on the left
and then has to check equality of its
own certificate
and the certificate it goes from you but
v doesn't have a certificate you send it
to b
in the classical setting we don't care
just keep a copy and send the copy
but here these are quantum bits you
can't replicate
so you have to do something more clever
what we do is to choose a chrono is to
send a certificate or keep it
and of course you can repeat it and
amplify
the success probability and so on so
this is
one interesting challenge no clone
property
and this also affects net challenge that
of reusing the states for
re-verification as i said the motivation
from
this uh all this mechanism of
quantum of distributed certification is
to check the state of the system
again and again and
do this as long as the state is okay
in the background without recomputing
certificates every time you want to
certify
to check the system is okay just do it
periodically the background and not
creating certificates
again and again so we have to reuse the
certificates
but then you have a problem because you
sent them that one problem in our
problem you check equality
so you have to make sure that check
inequality doesn't ruin the quantum
state and the last challenge i want to
mention
is what happens if your states are not
even product states
as i mentioned before you have
superposition of
several hash functions and hashes of
values
but what if your secret is so corrupted
that it's not even
in the form of this product state
and let's get a bit more into details so
the first detail is this quantum
fingerprint
as i mentioned this is a superposition
of hash functions
and with the right family of hash
functions we can get the following
property
if x equals y then the fingers the inner
product of the fingerprints of
x and y is one if x is different from y
then the inner product of their hashes
of their fingerprints
is smaller than a value epsilon that we
choose
okay so we have these fingerprints that
have this property of
very long distance between equality and
inequality
of the values you apply the shrinking
print on
and using this we can use the classical
swap test
this is a test for equality between
quantum states
and the test except with probability
half
plus the inner product square squared
over 2.
so if x and y are equal then the test
will always accept if x
and y are not equal then the probability
that they pass the test that the
fingerprints
pass the test is at most half plus
epsilon
and what we show in analysis that the
quantum states do not collapse
as long as x equals y so you can reuse
the certificates again and again
as long as the system is okay and the
replicated data is okay
and they stay their test actually can
handle
also non-product states so if the
certificate is really corrupted or the
proof tries to fool you
the test will still catch it and accept
only probability have plus
epsilon other challenges that i
will not talk about today is what
happened on general graphs not the path
as you see here but a more general graph
and then you have to check equality on
many many different parts and have maybe
more
more complicated certificates and
accordingly what happened we have more
than two terminals
and another thing we did in this paper
is to prove lower bound for the same
problem
in the non-quantum setting even for the
randomized case
the open questions and conclusions is
first of all that quantum bits give
exponential advantage
also received specification this was
known before for other settings
centralized or distributed
computation but not for certification
and the main open problem is to use this
idea
for uh verifying other world credit
cards of labor grafts
graphs or knowledge like straining
freeness or
symmetry of the graph using quantum
certificates
another question is proving lower bounds
we have some directions for this but
it's still
not entirely clear how to prove lower
bounds for using quantum
certificates and i will stop here and
thank you very much